>>> TONIGHT, 355 DAYS IN SPACE.
THAT IS THE LONGEST THAT ANY
AMERICAN HAS EVER BEEN IN SPACE,
NASA ASTRONAUT MARK VANDE HEI
BREAKING THE RECORD NOW BACK ON
EARTH, RECEIVED THIS CALL FROM
VICE-PRESIDENT HARRIS.
>> HOPE YOU FEEL OUR NATION, OUR
PLANET IS SO THANKFUL TO YOU FOR
YOUR YEARS OF DEDICATES SERVICE,
CERTAINLY TO OUR COUNTRY AND TO
YOUR DEDICATION TO SUCH
EXCELLENCE AND WELCOME HOME,
WELCOME HOME.
>> AND "OUTFRONT" NOW, THE
RECORD-SETTING MARK VANDE HEI,
MARK, I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
IT IS STUNNING TO CONSIDER WHAT
YOU DID AND HOW YOU, YOU ENDURED
IT.
I MEAN, WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO
SACRIFICE A FUEL YEAR OF YOUR
LIFE FOR THIS OBVIOUSLY VERY
IMPORTANT MISSION?
>> OH, I FEEL LIKE IT WAS PART
OF MY JOB, FRANKLY.
I FELT CERTAINLY HONORED THAT I
WAS ENTRUSTED WITH SUCH AN
IMPORTANT TIME IN SPACE, BUT I
FELT LIKE I REALLY HAD A LOT OF
GRATITUDE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE UP THERE AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE AS WE
CONTINUE EVERYDAY TO BREAK NEW
GROUND WITH SCIENCE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
GREATEST ACCOMPLISHMENT WAS FROM
BEING UP THERE?
>> GOSH, GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT, ONE SINGLE
THING, THAT'S HARD TO DO, HARD
TO DESCRIBE WHEN THERE'S 60 TO
100 EXPERIMENTS GOING ON AT ANY
GIVEN TIME, IF I HIGHLIGHT ONE
EXPERIMENT OF MANY, JUST TO TRY
TO MAKE THAT SEEM A LITTLE MORE
REAL, ONE I LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
IS CELESTIAL IMMUNITY.
IT WAS AN EXPERIMENT THAT
INVOLVED US TAKING SOME HUMAN
CELLS THAT WERE DONATED FROM
ELDERLY PEOPLE AND YOUNGER FOLKS
AS WELL AND INOCULATING THEM AND
SEEING HOW THE IMMUNE SYSTEM
RESPONSE CHANGED.
SO MY HOPE FOR THAT IS THAT
HELPS US WITH THAT KNOWLEDGE,
THAT IT HELPS FUTURE SPACE
EXPLORERS MAINTAIN THEIR HEALTH
AS THEY TRAVEL FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY FROM THE PLANET
SOMEDAY.
>> RIGHT, I KNOW THE GOAL, NEXT
TO MARS, YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT.
IN YOUR TIME UP THERE, YOU KNOW,
IT'S SUCH TIGHT QUARTERS WITH
PEOPLE, I ALWAYS FIND IT
INCREDIBLE TO EVEN IMAGINE IT.
I KNOW IT'S UNIMAGINABLE FOR
THOSE OF US WHO NEVER DONE IT
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU SPENT A LOT
OF TIME WITH INDIVIDUAL AND SOME
OF THEM OF COURSE ARE RUSSIANS,
ALWAYS RUSSIAN AMERICANS AND
S
OTHERS OTHER THERE, I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT WHAT KELLY SAID,
HE HAD THE RECORD IN SPACE UNTIL
YOU BROKE IT AND SAYING RUSSIA
IS BRAINWASHING THE COSMONAUTS
INTO SUPPORTING PUTIN'S INVASION
OF UKRAINE AND JUST SPOKE TO
NEWSWEEK I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW
THIS, BUT SAID HE'D BEEN
SPEAKING TO RUSSIAN COUNTER PART
AND SEE SAID MOST OF THEM ARE
REALLY FAR DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE,
SO THAT PART SURPRISED ME HOW
EASILY SOME OF THEM WERE MISLED
AND BRAINWASHED I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY AND DON'T BELIEVE WHAT
IS REALLY HAPPENING.
HE DID, THOUGH, CAVEAT, IT MARK,
SAYING SOME OF THE COSMONAUTS
ARE LIKE, THIS IS ALL AN F-ING
TRAVESTY AND RIDICULOUS AND I
WISH I COULD LEAVE THIS COUNTRY.
I KNOW YOU BECAME INCREDIBLY
CLOSE WITH THE RUSSIAN
COSMONAUTS YOU WERE WORKING
WITH.
YOU CONSIDER THEM VERY DEAR
FRIENDS.
DID YOU EXPERIENCE WHAT KELLY IS
TALKING ABOUT?
>> I CERTAINLY EXPERIENCED THE
FACT THAT HUMAN BEAKS FORM
OPINIONS BASED ON THE INPUTS
THEY RECEIVE AND WHAT THEY TEND
TO FOCUS ON, SO I THINK THE
WHOLE POLITICS OF THE UNITED
STATES FOLLOWS AS WELL, BUT MOST
OF MY INTERACTIONS WITH
CREWMATES EVEN THOUGH I WAS
CURIOUS ABOUT THEIR
PERSPECTIVES, PRIMARILY FOCUSED
ON WHAT OUR SPACE-RELATED TASKS
WERE AND COOPERATED WITHOUT
FAIL.
>> SO YOU AND RUSSIAN ASTRONAUT
ANTON HAD A TOUCHING EMBRACE
BEFORE THE DEPARTING CEREMONY,
AND HE SPOKE AT THAT MOMENT
ABOUT THE UKRAINE WAR AND THE
TENSION BETWEEN RUSSIA AND THE
UNITED STATES.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> PEOPLE HAVE PROBLEM ON EARTH.
ON ORBIT, WE ARE LIKE, WE ARE
NOT -- WE ARE ONE CREW.
AND I THINK ISIS IS LIKE A
SYMBOL OF THE FRIENDSHIP AND
COOPERATIONS AND LIKE SYMBOL OF
FUTURE OF EXPLORATION OF SPACE.
AND THANK YOU, VERY MUCH, MY
CREW MEMBERS.
WE ARE LIKE MY SPACE BROTHERS
AND SPACE SISTER.
>> AND OBVIOUSLY, YOU ALL WORK
TOGETHER.
BUT, YOU KNOW, GUESS YOU KIND OF
REFERENCE THIS, MARK, BUT YOU DO
IT AS A WAR IS WAGING BELOW YOU
ON EARTH, ACTUALLY SEEING IT
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
FRAGILITY OF THE ENTIRE PLANET,
LOOKING DOWN LOOKS BEAUTIFUL BUT
YOU KNOW INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE
DYING THERE.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> OH, GOSH, GETS ME CHOKED UP
JUST THINKING ABOUT IT.
I MEAN THE WORLD IS SO BEAUTIFUL
AND IT'S AWE INSPIRING TO LOOK
DOWN AT THE EARTH BUT IT'S ALSO
EXTREMELY SAD TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF SUFFERING
THAT'S HAPPENING AND PERSONALLY,
I THINK IT'S A VERY, VERY
AVOIDABLE SUFFERING.
AT THE SAME TIME, I FELT A
STRONG SENSE OF HONOR THAT I WAS
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN A PROGRAM
THAT I THINK HELPS PROVIDE A
PATH TO HAVING THE PEACE WE SO
DESPERATELY NEED IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE THOSE PATHS ALWAYS
REQUIRE SOME CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO TRUST EACH
OTHER.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
SPACE PROGRAM IS PROVIDING AND
HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE NO MATTER WHAT TYPE OF
INTERNATIONAL CONFLICTS WE RUN
INTO.
>> SO EVERYONE WATCHING THIS
CONVERSATION REMEMBERS THAT
SURPRISING IMAGE AND IT WAS
TALKED ABOUT ALL AROUND THE
WORLD WHEN THE LATEST GROUP OF
RUSSIAN COSMONAUTS ARRIVED AT
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
THE WAR HAD ALREADY BEGUN AND
THEY WERE WEARING THESE
INCREDIBLY BRIGHT YELLOW AND
BLUE FLIGHT SUITS.
AND EVERYBODY THOUGHT THAT
THERE'S NO WAY THIS COULD BE A
COINCIDENCE BECAUSE THESE ARE
THE COLORS OF THE UKRAINIAN FLAG
AND YOU GOT THE RUSSIAN
COSMONAUTS IN THIS WAR, GOING UP
THERE, BUT YOU SAY THEY WERE
BLIND SIGHTED BY THIS
CONTROVERSY, CAN YOU TELL ME
WHAT THEY TOLD YOU, WHAT YOU
LEARNED ABOUT THAT?
>> OH, I LEARNED THAT THOSE --
SO ALL THREE OF THOSE COSMONAUTS
WENT TO THE SAME UNIVERSITY IN
MOSCOW AND THOSE WERE THE COLORS
OF THAT UNIVERSITY.
I ALSO KNOW, HAVING PICKED OUT A
FLIGHT SUIT IN THE PAST, WE
GET -- THERE'S PART OF THE
PROCESS BEFORE LAUNCH IS THE
RUSSIANS GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PICK OUT CLOTHING.
AND IN SOME CASES YOU GET TO
PICK OUT SOMETHING THAT, WE'VE
HAD SOME, A CREW MEMBER FROM
MARYLAND, FOR EXAMPLE, HAD
COLORS OF THE STATE FLAG OF
MARYLAND ACROSS HIS CHEST AND
HAD, YOU KNOW, JUST ALL
DIFFERENT KIND OF CRAZY-LOOKING
FLIGHT SUIT, I TYPICALLY JUST
HAVE A U.S. FLAG AND BLUE FLIGHT
SUIT, I DIDN'T GET THAT FANCY
WITH IT.
SO MY FIRST REACTION TO SEEING
THEM WEARING THESE BRIGHT COLOR
FLIGHT SUIT AS WOW THAT WAS A
BOLD MOVE, NOT BECAUSE OF IT
HAVING ANY ASSOCIATION WITH
UKRAINE BUT JUST SUCH A BRIGHT,
FLAMBOYANT COLOR I JUST THOUGHT
THAT WAS SHOCKING.
ANTON ACTUALLY WHISPERED INTO
THEIR EAR, SAYING DID YOU INTEND
FOR THIS TO BE UKRAINIAN COLORS?
AND I REMEMBER ALYEG HAD A KIND
OF STARTLED LOOK ON HIS FACE,
THAT'S WHY WAS COMFORTABLE
SAYING THEY WERE BLIND SIDED
BECAUSE OF THAT NONVERBAL AND
KNOWING THEY WENT TO THE SAME
UNIVERSITY.
THEY CHOSE TO WEAR THE SAME
COLOR FLIGHT SUIT AND I'M SURE
THAT WAS BECAUSE OF THE
COMMONALITY IN WHERE THEY WENT
TO SCHOOL.
ALSO, THERE'S A LOT OF
BUREAUCRACY AND FIGURING OUT THE
CLOTHING YOU WEAR BEFORE YOU GO
TO SPACE.
SO YOU PICK THAT STUFF OUT
MONTHS IN ADVANCE, IT HAS TO GET
CONSTRUCTED, AND AS, YOU KNOW,
THAT TIMELINE WITH THE UKRAINIAN
INVASION WAS NOT TO TOO MUCH
BEFORE THEY ARRIVED, SO DIDN'T
HAVE